[Music]
we end today
with something rather exciting it's uh
not often that i'm out ahead of the
progressive curve i rarely get somewhere
before the woke bandwagon arrives
but that seems to be the case this time
there is this week controversy and
outrage over the netflix reality show
love is blind now for those with iqs
above 75 that have prevented you from
watching a show like this the basic
premise as i understand it is that
contestants are locked in isolation pods
where they meet other contestants by
talking to them through a wall
and they then i guess select which
disembodied voice they like the most
they talk some more to that person then
they get engaged before the big reveal
where they actually meet in person
at which point they're instructed to
fight to the death with their bare hands
now that would actually be a much better
show um in this one they they instead
get married and then as soon as the
cameras turn off they get divorced a
true
fairy tale romance
now there have actually been multiple
controversies around this show recently
the first is a lawsuit from a contestant
on an earlier season because they've
done multiple seasons of this show
because that's the sort of interest
there is in this content because we're
surrounded by morons and the contestant
alleges that producers starved him
deprived him of sleep
and forced him to get drunk all of which
makes the show sound way more
entertaining than it actually is but
that's not the controversy that matters
here the bigger outrage is over the fact
the show only features physically
attractive people i'm proud to say that
i spearheaded this woke backlash in a
youtube video we put out at the
beginning of the month where i reacted
to reality show trailers including one
for love is blind that was the first i'd
ever heard of love is blind and upon
seeing the commercial i immediately
pointed out this glaring flaw in the
plot everyone on the show appears to be
like a solid seven or eight and this
means there is nothing at stake nothing
on the line all the contestants end up
with attractive people
to give the show some suspense some
comedy some tragedy
you need to throw a few michael moores
into the mix
there should be a scene where a highly
attractive woman falls in love with a
man behind the wall
gets engaged then the big reveal happens
and she recoils in horror
when a character from the star wars bar
scene walks out
now that would be great television
matching supermodels with
ripley's believe it or not displays
i would sit down and watch a show like
that i would take the hit to my iq to
watch that show admittedly the wolf
criticism of love is blind is not quite
the same both me and the left are upset
that there are not ugly people on the
show but they're upset for a slightly
different reason for them the problem is
the lack of body diversity and inclusion
on the show
the backlash became severe enough that
one of the show's hosts vanessa lachey
who i assume is married to the you know
the guy from whatever backstreet boys
addressed in an interview with insider
claiming that um
there are no fat or ugly people on the
show because they're simply too insecure
to appear
there was like self-selection she said
but the mob
isn't buying that excuse buzzfeed took
her to task saying this is what they
wrote in their article if you've watched
love is blind you've probably definitely
noticed that the group of contestants
who make it to air don't reflect body
diversity like at all in a recent
interview with insider vanessa tried to
explain why the show doesn't embrace
body diversity in any real way her
answer was
not great in response to being asked
about the show's lack of body diversity
uh vanessa says she sometimes thinks
certain contestants don't make it past
the pods portion of the show
because uh they can't fit inside of it
that's actually not what she said
because they're they're insecure
so if i'm reading this right vanessa
vanessa's reason why the show doesn't
include diverse bodies in its cast is
because some contestants are simply too
insecure about their bodies to appear on
the show something tells me we might be
getting a clarification for vanessa in
the future regarding her comments or
maybe not either way we'll see if love
is blind goes in more diverse directions
casting wise when it returns for its
third season time will tell
well if nothing else we can agree that
buzzfeed continues to feature great
writing and important journalism
huffington post isn't buying vanessa's
excuse either they write love is blind
has yet to prominently feature a
contestant who is plus size visibly
disabled or older or older than 40 which
seems odd since the concept of the show
is to fall in love with someone's
personality rather than their physical
appearance
now of course
the real reason that the show only has
attractive people the reason that most
shows only feature attractive people
this current show that you're watching
is an exception
the reason is that viewers prefer to
watch attractive people hence the term
attractive
this is doubly the case if the show
revolves around love and romance
people may watch a show like my 600
pound life
but they probably wouldn't watch my 600
pound wedding
well they might watch that but for very
different reasons then they watch the
typical reality dating show and that's
about all that needs to be said about
this
but i'll say more anyway
because there's one more point i think
that needs to be made
huffington post says that the point of
the show
is for people to fall in love with
personality rather than physical
appearance
but the idea that you can love somebody
for their personality totally apart from
their appearance is a myth okay
it's a popular myth it's one that my
generation in particular was fed early
and often but it's a myth
of course you shouldn't and really can't
love somebody entirely for their looks
but their looks are an important part of
the package it's part of who they are
it's what draws you to someone
especially early in the relationship but
even as you grow together and you get to
know each other on a deeper level still
their appearance their body their
physical look and presence will remain
extremely important your body is not
just some sort of meaningless shell
which contains your personality and your
truer essence
your body is who you are
you're more than your physical body okay
you're not you're not merely your
physical body but you are also your body
it really is not possible
therefore to
love someone and not love their body
because their body is them this
distinction between looks and
personality doesn't even make sense
your personality
is what makes you as a person
different from other people
that includes your body your face your
physical appearance and mannerisms all
of that is part of your personality
because it's part of your person
it's what makes you you and not somebody
else
this is actually an important point for
two reasons neither of which have
anything to do with reality shows the
first is that people who really buy into
this appearance doesn't matter idea are
more likely to get married and then
completely let themselves go
transforming very quickly into a
physical specimen quite different from
the one that their spouse married
now obviously we all change over time
gradually as we get older but
we still have a responsibility in a
marriage to take care of ourselves
we should want to be physically
attractive to our spouses
it's quite selfish to throw that all to
the wind
and gorge ourselves with abandon
the second and deeper point is that our
culture is constantly trying to separate
the body from the person
as if these are two distinct things
in its most extreme iteration of course
we're told that a person with a man's
body can still be a woman and we're told
straight men can and should date these
trans women because though they have the
physical appearance of men they're
really women deep inside
but this is incoherent
as straight men we're attracted to women
not just for their bodies but their
bodies are certainly a significant
appeal it wouldn't make any sense at all
it would be totally unintelligible to
say that you're attracted to women but
you're neutral about their bodies
their bodies are what make them women
for all of us our bodies are what make
us who we are
this is
you know i think this conversation has
certainly gotten more esoteric than was
necessary for discussion about a netflix
dating show but i just go wherever the
path takes me
and now it takes me to a place where i
must say that
love is blind does not cancel
it's the critics of love is blind that
are today cancer
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really that's what it
is we're joined we're forming a cult
then all you gotta do is click the
subscribe button and ring the bell below
uh this video to stay up to date with
all my content and if you want even more
you can watch or listen to my show at
thedailywire.com spotify or apple
podcast looking forward to welcoming you
to the sweet baby gang